this is the story of the rise of an
automotive tycoon carlos gunn the ceo of
nissan a japanese conspiracy against
that tycoon which turned into one of the
most hostile of hostile takeovers in
history to where the ceo of nissan is
now a wanted fugitive the ouster
chairman of nissan has fled japan where
he was awaiting trial on financial
misconduct charges now he's in lebanon
he reportedly got there
in a musical instrument case i am not
making this up meanwhile we want to turn
to carlos gone's great escape let me
explain
december 29 2019 carlos ghon the ceo of
nissan leaves a tokyo apartment building
at 2 30 in the afternoon he walks
quickly and carefully on his way to meet
two men at a nearby hotel
those two men included michael taylor
and his son michael taylor was a former
u.s special forces soldier with the
green berets and mr taylor and his son
were hired by the nissan ceo to help him
on this trip
shortly after arriving the three men
leave the hotel and board a bullet train
headed to osaka
they arrived just after 8pm that night
to a hotel near the kansai international
airport a few hours passed and michael
taylor and his son then left the hotel
carrying several large boxes of musical
equipment and headed to the airports
hidden inside one of those boxes was the
third man the nissan ceo was huddled up
in a dark cramped box doing his best not
to make a sound at that time there have
been a lot of concerts in japan so two
men making their way through the airport
with large boxes of what appeared to be
musical equipment didn't set off any red
flags they arrive at the airport and
make their way through security all
their music equipment gets sent through
the x-ray machine except for that one
specific box containing the third man
this box was carefully selected to be
far too big to be sent through the x-ray
machine and since the two men had plenty
of other music gear with them another
giant music box wasn't all that
suspicious so security let that giant
box through without batting an eye they
get through security and make their way
to a private jets the luggage is loaded
on and once the plane took off carlos
gome was alerted that the coast was
clear the private jet eventually lands
at ataturk international airport in
instable turkey where the executive is
escorted to another private jets his
destination
beirut lebanon there the nissan ceo got
off his plane used his lebanese passport
to get through customs and heaved a sigh
of relief the ceo of nissan had just
successfully smuggled himself out of
japan with the help of a green beret and
his son carlos gome was one of the most
respected businessmen on the planet he
helped save michelin renault and nissan
from becoming unprofitable disasters and
on the 29th of december 2019 he escaped
up to 15 years in jail and getting fined
up to 90 million dollars in reparations
a multi-millionaire bonafide celebrity
business wizard and now a wanted
fugitive the question is why
[Music]
meanwhile we want to turn to carlos
ability to lift almost any business out
of bankruptcy made him a world famous
ceo with dozens of companies interested
in bringing him on board his skills are
what put him in such a high position of
power and if you develop your skills
hone in on your strengths you too can
skyrocket your career just like carlos
did that's where skillshare comes in
today's video sponsor skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes for people just
like you who are looking to take their
abilities and career to the next level
it allows you to build up real
profitable skills at a reasonable price
like this class on the art of turning
ideas into high growth businesses it's
taught by guy kawasaki and has more than
28 000 students or this series on
inclusive ux or user experience it's
taught by regina gilbert to get you
started on the basis of a web design
career right now skillshare is always
launching new classes and there are
never any annoying ads to interrupt your
learning so you're definitely going to
be able to find a ton of classes that
speak to you the world today rewards
competence people who are great at their
craft and if you want to up your
confidence sign up for skillshare right
now by clicking the link in the video
description below the first 1 000 of my
subscribers to do so will get a one
month free trial so you can start
discovering what skillshare has to offer
right now pause the video and click the
link below to get started
[Music]
carlos gome was the son of immigrant
parents and grandparents he was born in
brazil with lebanese and french
citizenship after studying as an
engineer he started working at the
michelin tire company in 1978 and he did
really well like insanely well just
three years after starting at michelin
he was promoted to plant manager in
france and in 1985 at just 30 years old
he was appointed ceo of michelin south
america with the goal of making michelin
south america operations profitable
again a goal he achieved after just two
years this was because of his unique
approach to managing multicultural teams
he famously said quote you learn from
diversity but you're comforted by
commonality end quotes joan did so well
as the ceo of mission south america that
just four years later he became the ceo
of michelin north america and a year
later he was promoted to ceo in just 11
years carlos gone had risen up to the
top one percent of the automotive
industry
after working at michelin for another
seven years gone decided it was time for
a new challenge he had made a name for
himself turning michelin around and now
he was looking for the next failing
company to save renault a french car
manufacturer was on the edge of
bankruptcy and desperately needed some
new blood to get the profitability again
and the man they hired was none other
than carlos gone in 1996 he became the
executive vice president of renault he
restructured all the company's
purchasing and manufacturing processes
and brought them back to profitability
just one year later he literally saved
renault a giant corporation with a ton
of moving pieces in just one year
something most businesses think is
almost impossible
by now gone was seen as a business
wizard he brought two companies back
into the black earning him the nickname
lacoste killer and every company in the
industry wanted his midas touch so in
1999 he decided to do it again and the
next target was a japanese auto legend
that was flopping nissan
[Music]
[Music]
in may 1999 renault bought a 36.8 stake
in nissan in what would become the
renault nissan alliance and gold's
ultimate test in managing multicultural
teams he was able to get europeans south
americans and north americans to play
along together but would he be able to
do the same with japanese culture
when carlos joined nissan had 20 billion
dollars in interest bearing debt and
only three other 46 models were making
any profit in japan it was an absolute
disaster management was complicated the
company was producing too many models
and it seemed like nissan was about to
collapse they needed some serious help
and lacoste killer was there to give it
to them we gotta start cutting the crust
off this [ __ ] sandwich while maintaining
his position at renault gone joined
nissan as a new ceo and in this new
position he vowed to do the impossible
again he would make nissan profitable in
just one year by the end of the year
2000. any set to cut their debt in half
by the year 2002. he called it the
nissan revival plan and if he failed he
promised he would resign it looked like
a suicide mission but by march 31 2002
he met his goals
but it came at a cost he cut 21 000 jobs
shut down five manufacturing plants and
so some of nissan's most prized assets
like their aerospace unit it was a
bloodbath
and you don't do anything like that
without making some enemies gone
basically ignored every single japanese
business custom in the book by turning
nissan's corporate structure upside down
he took away unconditional lifetime
employment which was part of the culture
there and stopped giving away promotions
based only on seniority which was
another custom in japan
see as a 100 asian myself i've seen both
sides and can confirm that asian culture
tends to be a little less racially
inclusive and much more prideful than
say western culture see what i did there
i made sure you knew i was asian first
so you can't cancel me ask any other
asian and they'll probably confirm so
put yourself in the shoes of an
executive at nissan you are a proud
japanese man at a proud japanese car
company with a lot of heritage you have
seniority you don't have to worry about
getting fired for the most part even
though the company is in bad shape
things are going pretty well for you you
have status and command respect then
comes in this westerner with his
arrogance and big attitude he starts
uprooting everything nissan is no longer
a 100 japanese company all he cares
about is profit he fired 21 000 japanese
people putting them on the street and
he's getting all the fame this is all
speculation but i would predict a lot of
resentment and envy started building up
red about then he was outshining the
masters and to add insult to injury by
june 2001 gone was appointed the ceo of
nissan for his outstanding work
[Music]
by 2002 nissan was one of the most
profitable car companies in the industry
gone had taken them from a 6 billion
loss to a 2.7 billion profit in a single
year but that wasn't enough he wanted
more more success more fame and
obviously more money so in may 2002 he
announced a new plan this year is going
to be another record year for the
industry
he would increase nissan's global sales
by 1 million achieve an operating margin
of 8 and completely eliminate all its
debt all by the end of september 2005 a
three year time frame
gome was in an all-out scramble to get
to the top he was going to be the best
and he would use nissan to prove it and
the cost killer strikes again not only
did he reach his goal but he did so so
well that renault even increased their
stake in the company to over 44
by now carlos gome was a superstar in
the business world his abilities got him
awards by fortune magazine's asia's
businessman of the year and time
magazine's list of global influentials
it was only natural that in 2005 gone
was named president and ceo of renault
too making him the first person to ever
run two fortune 500 companies at the
same time it seemed like gun could go
nowhere but up and for a few years that
was the reality but then 2008 hits and
it all starts going downhill fast
[Applause]
[Music]
it was the worst day on wall street
since the crash of 1987. we're down by
between three and four and a half
percent generally across these markets
traders here working the phones say a
lot of their customers are freaked out
waiting to see how low the dow will go
they're focused on the dow not so
focused on okay
[Music]
2008 was a bad year for everyone and
nissan was no exception the car market
dried up and people seemed reluctant to
spend their money on any sort of
investment gone's hard work was as sick
so he decided to push back harder with
more drastic measures than ever in 2009
he released the nissan gtr hoping it
would spark interest and sales in nissan
again in 2010 nissan debuted the
company's first ev the nissan leaf but
it seemed no matter what he tried
nothing could really get nissan back to
his spot as one of the most profitable
car companies in the world so he
switched lanes and started gunning for
more sales offering massive bonuses to
any car dealers who could meet the crazy
sales goals he set these bonuses were so
big car dealers would actually buy their
own cars just to reach the goal and then
sell the used cars they bought a few
months later driving up sales
artificially it was a desperate attempt
to get nissan back to the top but it was
all in vain
[Music]
carlos gone's desperate attempts to keep
nissan from syncing didn't work it was
doing more harm than good profits were
dropping and nissan executives started
panicking even though nissan was losing
money gone seemed to go on as usual even
buying a 34 stake in mitsubishi all the
while nissan struggled to stay afloat
lick cost's killer seem to have lost his
magical touch and it didn't help that at
the time gome was making 16.9 million
dollars a year and still wanted a bigger
salary even though he was being paid 11
times more than the ceo of toyota in his
mind he deserved it after all the hard
work he had done for nissan and to be
fair he was still getting paid less than
his american ceo counterparts and he
could easily leave nissan for any other
car company in america and be paid what
he's worth but the final straw was his
plan to merge renault and nissan as we
mentioned japan is a traditional
patriotic country nissan's board members
had tolerated gone's disregard for
japanese culture his demands for a
bigger salary and his ruthlessness
because he was making the money but as
profits fell more and more animosity was
building his huge salary his plans to
immerse nissan and renault which would
really make them not a japanese company
anymore i would collude with the french
government to establish a merger even
though i was against it and they decided
just to get rid of me in a way which
frankly is neither subtle nor very smart
so they colluded on a plan a plan to get
rid of their carlos gone problem this
conspiracy to oust carlos gone would
involve top-level nissan executives
police officers and some believe even
the japanese government it would be the
most hostile of hostile takeovers in
history
[Music]
november 2018 carlos gunn receives a
request to attend a meeting with nissan
board members in tokyo it was business
as usual so we got on a private jet and
made the trip to the tokyo international
airports he got off the plane went
through customs and then was arrested on
the spot at 4 30 pm on november 19 2018
he was charged with underreporting his
salary between 2010 and 2014 and was
taken to a detention center the world
was led to know that i was arrested in
the airplane
i was arrested in the airport i came
down from the airplane i was taken in a
car i arrived to the passport they told
me there's a problem with my visa they
took me in a small room and this is
where i found seki prosecutor telling me
i'm from the prosecutor office i need to
talk to you and since then say you
cannot use anymore your phone and i know
i was arrested i understand what's going
on
and
because i was surprised i told him okay
can i at least give a phone call to
nissan to send the lawyer but obviously
i didn't know that nissan was behind it
and it was all staged
way before between the prosecutor and
the company
in a few hours a world-renowned
businessman became little more than a
common criminal conveniently just three
days after his arrest nissan board
members casted a vote a vote to remove
gon as the chairman four days later
mitsubishi voted him out as well the man
that saved nissan was stabbed in the
back by the very people he saved for
nissan their enemy was out of the
picture but for carlos gone the trouble
was just starting gome was accused of
underreporting his pay by 10 million
dollars a year of using nissan funds to
buy property all over the world and of
secretly adding crazy amounts of money
to his retirement fund every year
instead of being let out on bail he was
kept in solitary confinement not for
being a violent criminal but for being
accused of white-collar crime
so i was arrested for a compensation
that was not fixed that was not decided
and that was not paid this is the reason
of my arrest
this is the reason of my risk well i can
tell you that in many countries there is
no reason to arrest it's certainly not a
criminal case it's certainly not a
even an offense and new charges kept
being added every week so that in the
end carlos gomez spent 108 days in
solitary confinement being questioned
daily without the chance of getting bail
or even talking to a lawyer more than 3
months in solitary confinement for a
charge that most people would have
gotten bail for within days 130 days in
prison solitary confinement tiny cell
without window light day and night
30 minutes per day
excluding weekend because obviously
there is not enough garden in the
weekend you can't go for 30 minutes
outside when there is a holiday there is
nobody so you stay in your cell you just
get your food
for example sixth day
without any human contact during the new
year break
shower twice a week
try to ask to have more they said no
prescribed medication is forbidden you
can get only the medicine from the
prison interrogated days and night
can happen in the morning in the
afternoon at night
up to eight hours obviously without the
presence of a lawyer all of this is
taped impossible to take to anyone no
one speak english or french or anything
when we need something important we have
to bring somebody and this guy is
available once a week presumption of
guilt prevail prosecutor from the
beginning you know they let me to know
you're guilty
you know don't play games confess
and everything they were asking me is
not to try to discover the truth is to
try to find reason
to make sure that their accusation will
be stronger
it turns out that one of the guys
involved in keeping guns books was hari
nada hari nada decided to take a deal
with the police and turned against gun
to avoid being charged alongside him
that's where the police got all their
information nissan board members even
tried to hack gone's emails to get more
dirt on him all this meant that carlos
gone spent 108 days in jail with no
contact with his lawyers or family every
time he tried to get bail new charges
were added so he had to spend more time
in jail finally after three months of
being in jail gum was released on bail
on march 2019 for 1 billion yen or
around 9 million
he was kept under 24 hour video
surveillance and wasn't allowed any
internet access which became an issue
when a month later he tweeted that he
was quote
ready to tell the truth end quote a day
later he was arrested again on new
charges five days after his second
arrest shareholders voted to remove him
from the nissan board entirely this time
his detention only lasted a couple weeks
though he was eventually released back
to house arrest where he stayed for
almost a year he couldn't use the
internet unless he was under supervision
he couldn't leave japan he was followed
wherever he went and he had almost no
contact with his wife or family in his
eyes it didn't look like he had any
chance whatsoever of getting a fair
trial in the japanese judicial system
these allegations are untrue
and i should have never been arrested in
the first place
[Music]
in december 2019 more than a year after
his first arrest carlos gomez makes his
daring escape from japan in a box all
the way to lebanon where he still is
today quote when you get in the box you
don't think about the past you don't
think about the future you just think
about the moment you're not afraid you
don't have any emotion except a huge
concentration on this is your chance you
can't miss it if you miss it you're
gonna pay with your life with the life
of a hostage in japan
even though lebanon and japan are in
good terms they don't share extradition
treaties so for the time being gone is
safe with his family but for the nissan
execs and the guy who helped them escape
their future isn't looking quite as
bright
[Music]
it turns out the new ceo of nissan a man
named hiroto sakawa was just as guilty
as gon himself he eventually admitted to
also secretly increasing his salary over
the years which started raising
questions as to why the nissan board
members really wanted gone out of the
company was it really because they found
out he was getting paid more than he
disclosed or was it a mix of envy greed
at an opportune moment well old nissan
had always worked against me since 1999.
whatever their reasons there was a
massive conflict of interest since the
same board members who collected
evidence and conducted an internal
investigation were also the guys lining
their own pockets then comes another
twist
ravinder passie who's nissan's top
lawyer becomes a whistleblower he
revealed that the snitch hari nanda had
told them about the arrest beforehand
and that there was an investigation
against gun for misconduct while at the
same time hari nada have been helping
gong hide his money ever since he joined
nissan while taking some for himself too
for nissan's top lawyer things didn't
add up how could someone who is
implicated in the investigation and
accusations be part of the investigative
team so raven dear passing leaked this
information did it lead to the
whistleblower being praised for
potentially exposing a criminal
conspiracy no it led to mr posse being
ordered to leave japan in a matter of
days in may 2020. his apartment was
rated for evidence while his wife and
four daughters had to stand by and watch
they tried the exact same thing with mr
passi as they did with carlos gone it's
as if nissan could potentially have some
police under their payroll whether or
not nissan executives would be held
accountable is yet to be determined but
all the information released by carlos
gunn and ravender passi makes it seem
like the case was never so black and
white and that there may be some merit
in ghost claims that patriotism and
greed made them do it i had some
suspicion on the justice system in japan
when i've seen so many scandals
[Music]
for now carlos gone is safe in beirut
where he's living with his wife and
family and trying to build a case
against nissan that would be heard in
any court outside of japan japan has
issued a red notice for his arrest
through interpol
michael taylor and his son peter who
both helped young sneak out of japan
weren't so lucky on may 20th 2020 peter
and his son were arrested in the us a
few months later the u.s agreed to
extradite them to japan and in july 2021
after pleading guilty to their charges
michael was sentenced to two years in
prison and his son got 20 months there
was no mention of the more than 800
thousand dollars both men were paid to
get gone out of japan
after admitting to have received 440
thousand dollars from nissan as a
mistake hiroto sakawa the guy who led
the investigations against gon resigned
as ceo in 2019 he has not been charged
for any crime
[Music]
hiring nada snitch still works at nissan
as the senior vice president his deal
with the japanese police seem to have
paid off really well
and ravinder passi the lower turn
whistleblower he doesn't work for nissan
anymore either he got fired soon after
sharing information on the conspiracy
against gon since gone's arrest nissan
and renault have lost almost 30 billion
dollars in market value
even after renault tried slashing jobs
and cutting down production two of gun's
signature moves the company is still
struggling so is carlos innocent was he
just doing stuff you expect a ceo to do
did you know japan could be so corrupt
because in the west japan is painted as
this idyllic paradise let me know what
you think in the comments below
what's up guys i'm still in the middle
of moving so hence the blank background
it'll be like this for the next few
videos but we're still doing the iphone
13 giveaway all you have to do is be
subscribed to this channel you don't
have to like read subscribe or anything
if you're already subscribed but yeah
subscribe and i will pick the winner in
probably like the next one to two weeks
yes it will actually be a random
subscriber that wins not some rigged
competition and all you gotta do is
subscribe which you should if you're new
here because we make video essays
documentaries just like this one every
single week on the most provocative
stuff in the world of money power war
and crime if you want more day in the
life kind of stuff you can follow me on
instagram jaketrend.io that's going to
wrap it up thank you so much for being
part of the watch the end club stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you